DYLAN THOMAS: Hello and welcome
to What's New in
Enterprise Maps.
My name is Dylan Thomas.
I am an enterprise community
maps manager.
And with me today
is Ajay Hemnani.
AJAY HEMNANI: Hi, Dillon.
DYLAN THOMAS: Hi.
Ajay is a education specialist
on the Enterprise team.
He travels the world teaching
our partners and customers how
to get the most of
our products.
So as you may know as a
customer, every 90 days we do
a forward looking product
road map.
And we thought it would
be pretty nice--
Ajay and I thought it would
pretty nice-- to maybe look at
what we got accomplished in the
last 90 days with that.
And to that end, we want to take
a look at three products
and several releases that we've
done over the past 90
days, and go into those in
a little bit more depth.
So today we're going to talk
about Google Maps Engine.
And we have three things
to talk about there.
The first one is simpler
domain provisioning.
The second one is vector
editing in the browser.
And the third one is some
changes we've made with CSV
handling, so file uploads
for text files.
Then we're going to switch gears
and look at some OAuth
work with the client libraries
for Coordinate.
And finally, we're going to
give you a reminder on the
deprecation of the version 2
JavaScript API, which is
happening on November 19.
So with that introduction,
let's look at
the first item, Ajay.
AJAY HEMNANI: Thanks.
Thanks, Dylan, for the intro.
All right.
So the first one I'm going to
talk about today is simpler
domain provisioning
for Maps Engine.
I guess the best way for me to
deduce this would be now we
have a slightly better answer
for apps customers who in the
past would say, why do I have to
provision a new sub-domain
and register Google Apps
if I already have one?
Because in the past these two
things, Google Apps and Maps
Engine, cannot coexist
on the same domain.
Today we have a better
answer for them.
So to be more specific,
previously if you were an Apps
customer with a domain
appcustomera.com, we would
need you to create
a sub-domain--
let's say gme.appscustomera.com.
Register Google Apps on it.
Order Maps Engine
on that domain.
And once the order goes through,
you will have Maps
Engine running on that
domain but not Apps.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
And for customers who are not on
Google Apps, we would still
recommend them to do the same,
provision a sub-domain,
register at Google Apps.
Because the idea is hopefully
somewhere along the way they
will want to buy Google Apps.
And typically, they want to
provision in on the high
level, top level domain.
And so we want to keep that
free, just in case they decide
to purchase Google Apps.
DYLAN THOMAS: So let me
try that back at you.
So if I already was an Apps
customer and I decided I
wanted Maps Engine, I would need
to have a sub-domain to
avoid a conflict between the
two products previously.
If I didn't have Apps,
we would think,
that's sort of crazy.
You'll probably want
them in the future.
So maybe you should go with
the same scheme anyway.
So that when you buy
Apps, you wouldn't
have a conflict happening.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right
DYLAN THOMAS: So what's
different now?
AJAY HEMNANI: Well, what's
different now-- and I'm really
excited about this is now we can
have Google Apps and Maps
Engine coexist on
the same domain.
So what I'm saying is if
you're an Apps customer
today-- again appscustomera.com,
that's
where you have your Google
Apps running.
You can use the same domain to
provision Maps Engine on it.
So you'll have all the apps,
like Gmail, Calendar, and so
on and so forth, with
Maps Engine
running on the same domain.
And in future if you want to
get coordinate, all three
could coexist on the
same domain.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
So it's just flexibility.
So I see the little
smiley face there.
I guess that's indicating
there's as a happy path, which
is do whatever you
want, basically.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly that.
DYLAN THOMAS: So to be clear,
if you want to have a
sub-domain for a GME you can.
AJAY HEMNANI: You can
still do that.
DYLAN THOMAS: And there
are reasons
for doing it, I suppose.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly right.
I was just going to say that,
if you have a bunch of users
that work using Google Apps and
a whole different bunch of
users who are going to be doing
Maps editing and loading
the maps from Maps Engine, and
these people are two separate
identities, you want to keep
them separate, you can still
go the same way we used to.
You can still get a sub-domain
and do like
what we used to do.
DYLAN THOMAS: Excellent,
great.
And so this is for all
customers, right?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
So that's a great
question, Dylan.
So today this works for
everybody except EDU domains
and GOV domains.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh, I thought
you were going to
say for every one.
AJAY HEMNANI: Well hopefully
we're going to
reach there very soon.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, all right.
So the plan is to roll
it out to everyone.
But we're not quite there yet.
But this is exciting enough
that we want to tell
everyone right now.
AJAY HEMNANI: Yup.
DYLAN THOMAS: Excellent,
great.
So now we were going to move
on and maybe take a look at
some vector data management
in the browser.
AJAY HEMNANI: I'm going to jump
right into my Maps Engine
console and load up one of the
vector tables that I have
uploaded previously.
Click on the vector table icon
that appears in the Data
Sources section.
And what I see here is a
whole list of points.
I'm going to go ahead and click
on one of the points.
And what I can see now through
the UI are two links that
allow me to either edit the
attributes of this feature or
edit the geometrics.
So I'm going to show, by using
the Move Point link to move
the point to somewhere
else on the map.
And click Save to make sure
the changes are saved.
And now as you can see on the
screen, the point has moved
from its original location
to the new location.
And just to complete the story,
let's click on the
Attributes.
And what I see at the bottom
right here is the record
belonging to this feature.
And I can just go directly
into the cell and make
changes like this.
DYLAN THOMAS: If I was going to
access that a second later
from the API, would I see
the updated feature now?
Is this sort of an
instantaneous--
well, fairly fast, let's say--
update to the record?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right
exactly that.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK got it.
Nice.
AJAY HEMNANI: And that's
not the only
thing that has changed.
So we also have access into
the vector table.
Vector table's basically the
structure we use internally
for vector uploads.
And so if I click on this icon
on the right hand side at the
top of the screen, it gives me
a spreadsheet-like thing
displaying the attributes
as columns and
the features as rows.
And I can just choose any
feature that I want to edit.
And make the edit and
go ahead and save.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's nice.
So you don't have to use a third
party package, and then
make an update, and re upload
the file, or write something
in the API to do simple
edits like that.
You could just give a map editor
access to this data.
And they could-- just
like a spreadsheet--
make some simple updates.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right, exactly
that, Dylan.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, but
that's too easy.
So what about a real feature,
like a Polygon,
or a line, or something?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
We can do that too.
However, I do want to add that
today, this functionality is
designed based on how the APIs
are doing their work.
And so the same limits apply.
And to show you that, let me go
back to my data sources and
show you an example
with a polygon.
And the reason I want to use
this example is because when I
click on this, it shows
the info window.
And I go ahead and click
on Edit Polygon.
This would have worked.
But in this case since
it's beyond the limit
that applies to APIs--
like I said, the same
limits apply to
this feature for now--
I get this pop-up error that
says that it has exceeded the
two vertices limit, which
is 2000 I believe today.
DYLAN THOMAS: And so these
limitations in the API, well
certainly the GME based platform
keep increasing and
increasing with table size.
But now realistically, there's
some limitation to what you
want to be doing in
a web browser.
So if you've got a million
vertex feature, you probably
still want to manage those in
maybe an external system and
perform an update or an upload,
right, potentially?
AJAY HEMNANI: Yes.
DYLAN THOMAS: Nice, OK.
So we were going to move on to
the third thing, which is
working with CSVs.
And there's some good news
on that front too, right?
AJAY HEMNANI: And so for
CSVs, we have two
things that have changed.
The first is now we don't any
longer need a VRT file when
you upload CSVs that
have latitude
and longitude columns.
So what I'm trying to say is
you can just dump in the
Lat,Lng columns in a CSV file
and upload it without a
accompanying VRT file that we
needed to in the past to
describe the contents
of the CSV.
DYLAN THOMAS: And so-- sorry,
just to back up there for the
people who are managing the
data upload today, they're
probably familiar
with a VRT file.
But if you're a map publisher
and you're watching this, the
VRT is sort of a side-by-side.
It tells Maps Engine previously
what's in the CSV
file so it can interpret
it correctly.
Map projection and things
like that, right?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, but you're
saying now you can, if you've
got the right columns in the
CSV, you don't need that
second file.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it, OK.
AJAY HEMNANI: And to
show that, I'll
just do a quick demo.
What I have right here is a CSV
file with three columns,
latitude, longitude, and name.
And just to spice up a little
bit, I have the column
latitude in uppercase, longitude
in mixed case.
I'm going to show you how I go
upload this through the Maps
Engine console.
DYLAN THOMAS: So let's just say,
we're using five rows in
this one, which is not
particularly adventurous.
But we can upload 100,000
at a time.
AJAY HEMNANI: Yes.
DYLAN THOMAS: So we're just
doing this because we need it
to work quickly for demo.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly. that.
Now that I've uploaded the CSV
file, let's just try to
quickly refresh and see if
it's done processing.
If I click on the vector table
map display, I can see the
point right here.
If I go ahead and click, it will
show me the name column
that you had seen in the
original file that I uploaded.
Now what happens is--
well, two interesting
observations.
First, the column names
are case insensitive.
So it doesn't matter how
you type it out.
The other thing is the latitude
longitude columns
don't show up as attributes.
So they're really geometry
information.
And they go in and decide
where the point
is going to be shown.
So the only attribute that
remains is the name column
right here.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
Well again, that was maybe
a little too easy, right?
So I think the other thing we
were going to talk about is
the geocoding side of
things, where you
don't have an xy column.
Maybe you just have the
name of a place
or some street addresses.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right, so I have
that example as well.
So let's say you did not have
the Lat,Lng attributes.
And you only had the
textual address.
What Maps Engine can
do for you is let
you upload this file.
And once upload is done, in the
post processing stage it's
going to actually make use of
the geocoding back end that
our geocoding API uses and
translate this textual address
into a Lat,Lng column, into a
Lat,Lng pair, and use that to
display the feature.
DYLAN THOMAS: Well, that's
pretty awesome.
That's a really powerful
geocoder that can take
honestly some pretty dirty
content in terms of the
cleanliness of an address
or places.
So this is a pretty nice way of
doing some bulk geocoding.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
And so let me just quickly
demo that.
So again, I'm going to upload
the file that I
just showed on screen.
And now what I see on the map
are exactly the two addresses
that I had entered.
And when I click on this, it
does show me the textual
address, because it's not
considered geometry
information.
It's taken as a column of
it's own attribute.
And it does show up in
the Info window.
DYLAN THOMAS: Cool.
Now, this one is experimental
still.
Which part of that?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
So that's an interesting thing
that you brought up, Dylan.
So right now we have the
experimental tag attached to
this feature.
So what that really means is
it's not covered by SLA.
And we also have a limit applied
today so can't upload
more than 100,000 textual
addresses in a single file.
DYLAN THOMAS: And that
was the important
distinction you made.
The uploading CSVs,
it's released.
Geocoding those with the textual
addresses is the
experimental part.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, got it.
AJAY HEMNANI: And so today we
are not charging map loads.
But once we remove the
experimental tag, we could be
charging map loads for every
geocoded feature.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, great.
Well we've got two more
things to show.
I think the next one we were
going to look at was the
client side libraries to work
with the coordinate API.
AJAY HEMNANI: So for most of our
developers who work with
Google APIs, you're trying
to do one of two things.
You're either trying to access
not private data, for example
using geocoding API to
geocode a textual
address into Lat,Lng.
Or you're trying to access
private data, maybe using
coordinate API to list on all
the jobs and workers in your
[INAUDIBLE] account.
So when you work with non
private data, you use the API
key, which you can easily get
from the API console.
When you're working with APIs
that use private data, you
will need to implement
OAuth 2.0.
And for developers who've
tried this out, you will
understand that it could
actually translate into
multiple lines of code and also
increase the chances of
making errors there.
That's exactly where the client
libraries come in.
They make it a lot easier,
because they come with methods
that make the OAuth dense
implementation a lot easier
for the application.
DYLAN THOMAS: So these are
libraries that Google has
provided that basically work
with a variety of our APIs.
And they're implemented in a
bunch of different languages
that you probably are already
using, right?
AJAY HEMNANI: Exactly.
So you have libraries for
Python, Java, and whatnot.
One thing about the libraries
though is that it's not
supported by Enterprise
support.
But we do highly recommend the
usage of these libraries.
Because they make the
implementation, rather the
coding, a lot simpler and reduce
the chances of you
having errors.
So for my demo, I'm going to
show a tool that I've been
working on.
A slight modification
of that, actually.
And I'm going to show you the
JavaScript version and also
the web server version of it.
Well, the web server have
chosen to run it
on App Engine Python.
So I'm going to use the even
easier version of the client
library that's available
for App Engine Python
implementations.
DYLAN THOMAS: I love
this demo.
There's an even easier
version.
AJAY HEMNANI: So let's
dive into it.
So for the JavaScript example
I have here, is an app that
basically accepts a team ID from
your coordinate account.
And it fetches the jobs and
workers from your account.
And so the first thing it's
going to do is check if
you're logged in.
Since I'm already logged in,
it's going to prompt me for
the authorization.
And so once I click on Accept,
I am authorized.
All I've got to do is dump
in the team ID, click on
Populate, and it populates.
This is part of an example that
I've been working on,
slightly modified.
And so what you can see this
drop down list, it's fetching
the jobs and the list of worker
accounts that are
available from my coordinate
account.
I just want to share what the
code looks like and I've made
use of the library.
So right here is where I'm
loading the library,
apis.google.comjsclient.js.
And once it's loaded,
I run some of the
methods that are available.
Let me just show you that.
So upon loading, I run this
method that sets the API key--
again if you are working
with non private data--
and I also do the OAuth pieces
using gapi.auth.authorize.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, that looks
pretty straightforward.
AJAY HEMNANI: Exacty.
And if you were to do this
without the client library,
this would again be multiple
lines of code.
I haven't really done the
handling of the auth result,
but you're free to do so.
You can just put some messages
for the user.
And once that's done, there's
three options really for you
to use the token that
can be generated.
I've used the [INAUDIBLE]
option, and there's great
documentation on the other
options as well.
You just dump the access
token with the API
call that you're making.
And you get results.
DYLAN THOMAS: Cool.
And so the thing we should
just wrap up on this one
saying is a reminder that we
were talking about Coordinate.
Because that's what you've seen
a lot of the experience
in your training recently it is
the OAuth confusion, let's
say, with that.
But this applies equally well
to Google Maps Engine.
And in fact, even
non enterprise
products as well, Right?
AJAY HEMNANI: Mostly
Google APIs.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, cool.
Excellent.
AJAY HEMNANI: Now, if you were
doing the same thing server
side, again, we have client
libraries to help you there.
In this example, I've used the
even easier version, like I
mentioned earlier, of
the client library.
This exists especially when
you're working with Python for
App Engine applications.
And so what we have is what we
call the OAuth 2 decorator
class for any developer who's
worked with OAuth implementing
OAuth in their code.
They would already be
familiar with flows,
and credential objects.
So the cool thing about this is
it allows you to not worry
about all those things.
Because this class handles
all those objects.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's nice.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
And so let me just jump into
the code right away.
And again, just like the client
side example, here you
would import the OAuth to
decorator class, create the
decorator object with your
client ID secret and scope,
the information that you'll
get from an API console.
And start using it after
you create the
authorize HDTV object.
So here is an example
of, how do I get the
authorize HTTP object?
And the next line shows the code
for extracting a list of
jobs from my coordinate account
with the authorized
HTTP object right here.
DYLAN THOMAS: Very nice.
Well, like you said, it seems
like the very easy version.
Thank you.
So I think we wanted to wrap
up the show with just a
reminder and a mention of
something that's happening in
Q4 this year, actually
on November 19.
And that's the final shutdown
of the version 2 JavaScript
API for Maps, right?
AJAY HEMNANI: Right,
exactly Dylan.
So what's going to happen is
beyond this date if you
request with the version 2 the
JavaScript API, you're going
to be served a wrapped version
of versing 3 of
the JavaScript API.
What this means is your simpler
applications will work.
But if there's anything complex,
it may not work.
So we're urging everybody who's
still on version 2 to
start thinking about upgrading
into version 3.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
And I think when you say it's
wrapped and the simpler things
will work, this is not something
you want to call to
open up a support case with
your enterprise agreement.
This is just, we're trying to
make the migration easier.
But what you really need to
be doing at this point is
aggressively pursuing that
migration and testing, so that
you can launch on November 20
with a fresh API version.
AJAY HEMNANI: Right.
And so I would also recommend
everybody who has not taken a
look at the upgrade guide
to just give it a look.
There's a lot of good pointers
and guidance on how to go
about upgrading from version
2 to version 3.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great, thanks.
And I think we're going to put
the URL for that on the show
screen here.
And with that, Ajay, I want to
thank you very much for giving
us a quick tour of what's
great and new in the
Enterprise Map space.
And we'll see you next time in
What's New in Enterpsie Maps.
Thank you.